okay so now you know what I did decide
you got your head wrapped around them
we're going to look at four cubic
identities today but before I show them
to you I need you to understand two
crucial questions and there's an acronym
for these two questions I'm pointing out
here because I want you to ask these two
questions all the time about everything
but particularly about mathematics and
particularly about these identities I'm
going to show you I am iw it stands for
it stands for I notice I wonder these
are the questions that all
mathematicians ask whenever they're
working they they pull around and
there's a point and prod and they
explore and every time they're always
thinking I notice here what can I see
what can I observe and then who wonder
what happens if we try what would be the
result if I mucked around with it in
this way so now you've got those two
ideas in your head four identities the
first one I wants to start with is the
cube of a Sun now for words two of them
are just conjunctions get any to worry
about them a cube is when you raise
something to the power of three and the
sum is just when you're adding two
things together okay so if I take an
arbitrary Sun and by arbitrary I mean
those A's and B's that could be anything
and I cube it I'm going to give you a
one-minute head start
can you go ahead and you can expand that
for me this thing is factorized right
we're looking at factorizing expanding
so far can we go ahead and expand out it
might take you two or three to four
lines and tell me what you do
go ahead I'll give you some time to make
a jump oh yeah okay thank you hands down
now it's okay if you didn't write it
exactly not that maybe your water is
slight
different you should have those terms
though okay now there's a good reason
why I have written it in this order and
I'm glad let's get more consistent I'm
gonna ask you these questions what do
you notice about this loan anything just
like one little idea yeah you can group
them in send it again a bit yeah yeah
okay so when you have a look at these
four right this looks like one of the
kinds of questions you've done in the
past few exercises it's always like
begging to be factorized because you can
see how things are paired out and that
should be surprising because it came
from something that was super factorize
okay very good what else do you know
yeah okay so when you have a when you
pay attention to two powers let's have a
look there's two sets of powers aren't
there right
you've got the a powers and then you've
got the three powers I think you're
talking about the aides weren't you so
the way that most of us was written it
is with descending powers of a so in
fact there's an end of the one here and
in fact there's also an A here isn't it
how many days do I have on this last
time I have zero so it's aid the north
okay and you've got the same thing
happening in Reverse cool what else does
he notice someone else doesn't say
anything yet I notice more things so we
don't usually write when a coefficient
is one a wave on it is helpful in this
case to do it because noticing he knows
it is first starters it's symmetrical
it's very nice and in fact some of you
have seen this result before and you may
have just gone straight to that line it
is quite easy to remember what you know
to expect that there's going to be a
symmetrical pattern so there's a
symmetrical pattern of coefficients also
those coefficients are just symmetrical
those are special numbers what are we
seeing one three three in one before
where have we seen it
I forgot the name I'm pretty sure we've
seen it it's like that here
Halloween what's this thing called again
Pascal's triangle okay though actually
because it's such an important
mathematical object it's discovered and
rediscovered over and over again
throughout history don't know how Pascal
got his name on it good luck this one
three three one can you see it's the
next line of Pascal's triangle isn't it
okay do you notice anything else have we
exhausted all of the properties and
characteristics of this thing I don't
think we have but pretty satisfied at
the moment I think we've got most of the
important things because this final line
I'm going to expect you to remember it
okay now yeah maybe this is the first
time you've looked in you think my
goodness how many symbols are there but
I promise you those things that we just
noticed are very they give a sort of
nice rhythm to this this object it's
actually quite easy to remember when you
think about all these objects I wonder
something which is I said that this is
the next line of Pascal's triangle right
what I wonder is why on earth does this
have anything to do with Pascal's
triangle like really why and secondly
what if I changed so numbers let's say
that one right what would happen and why
would it happen next topic we'll have a
look at that I just want to slay that
sugar cube of a saga huh give yourself
or get used to that if you don't like
that cue the Sun the next thing we're
going to look at is the cube of a
difference which is when you don't add
when you subtract
okay now a cute of the difference is
instead of a plus B if I have a minus B
that's the difference and that's the
cube okay now what I could do is I could
last me to rehearse this process all
over again I could say can you expand it
out just like we did before and then see
what you end up with at the end however
mathematicians famously lazy always
searching for ways to minimize the
amount of work they've done what are the
main ways that we do that is we look at
work that we've already done and we say
can I take advantage of this when I
solve a new problem okay
now this is a cube of a difference but I
can actually write this difference as a
sum and the way we can do it is with
this lonely button that you never use
how can I write this difference as a sum
instead of difference yeah something
like that yeah just take a factory okay
so let me give you a clue maybe you're
not that far from this right he followed
this to be a sum then the operation it
has to be addition right but adding
something which is the same as
subtracting is really why you've never
used this button before right because
adding a negative is after all the same
as Johnson subtractive right so do you
see what I've done I've turned a
difference into a sum which means I can
just go straight to this line it's just
the instead of writing B every time I've
written to be here what am I gonna write
instead careful what am I gonna write
instead I'm gonna write negative babe
okay so let's just go straight to the
punchline right I'm gonna rewrite it but
every time I see be down here I will
replace it with negative B so the first
time is a cute doesn't change
the next term is going to be three a
squared times negative B all right I
know it's such a it's such a reflex to
say minus B but actually these things
are different the next thing is three a
and negative B gets squared and then
lastly negative B is going to get are
you okay with that yeah so now having
done a straight substitution I can
simplify by sorting out all these
negative signs okay so what happens to
this one
yeah I can reverse my trick right I
don't need to write it as the sum of a
negative thing I can go back to saying
well this is a subtraction now that's 3a
squared B this one double may be nice
are they going to cancel each other out
and then in the end there are three
negative signs hiding in there two of
them cancel each other out leaving you
with one and I'm going to convert that
into a subtraction are you happy yeah
okay so that's the cube of the
difference again I'm gonna ask you to
remember it mainly by using it lots of
things are the same what what things are
the same okay so yeah the increasing DC
decreasing thing right I can write it in
exactly the same way here what else is
the same
yeah the coefficients their values are
the same is still the one 331 okay
what's the only thing that has changed
yeah the operations are gonna be
alternating here right so you add
subtract add subtract that's it